what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice applying
u-substitution to definite integrals
so let's say we have the integral so
we're going to go from x equals 1 to x
equals 2 and the integral is 2x times x
squared plus 1 to the 3rd power DX so I
already told you that we're going to
apply use substitution but it's
interesting to be able to recognize when
to use it and the key giveaway here is
well I have this x squared plus 1
business of 3rd power but then I also
have the derivative of x squared plus 1
which is 2x right over here so I could
do the substitution I could say U is
equal to x squared plus 1 in which case
the derivative of U with respect to X is
just 2x plus 0 or just 2x I could write
that in differential form a mathematical
hand wavy way of thinking about it is
multiplying both sides by DX and so you
get D U is equal to 2 X DX and so at
least this part of the integral I can
rewrite so let me at least write so this
is going to be I'll write the integral
we're going to think about the bounds in
a second so we have U to the third power
you do the same orange color U to the
third power that's this stuff right over
here and then 2x times DX
remember you could just view this as 2x
times x squared plus 1 to the third
power times DX so 2x times DX well 2 x
times DX that is d u so that and that
together that is d u now an interesting
question because this isn't an
indefinite integral we're not just
trying to find the antiderivative this
is a definite integral so what happens
to our bounds of integration well
there's two ways that you can approach
this you can change your bounds of
integration because this one is x equals
1/2 x equals 2 but now we're integrating
with respect to U so one way if you want
to keep your bounds of integration or if
you want to keep this a definite
integral I guess you could say you would
change your bounds from U is equal to
something to U is equal to something
else and so your bounds of integration
let's see when X is equal to 1 what is U
well when X is equal to 1 you have 1
squared plus 1 so you have 2 u is equal
to 2 in that situation when X is equal
to 2 what is U well you have 2 squared
which is 4 plus 1 which is 5 so U is
equal to 5 and you won't typically see
someone writing u equal to or u equals 5
it's often just from 2 to 5 because
we're integrating with respect to u you
assume it's u equals to 2 u equals 5 and
so we could just rewrite this as being
equal to the integral from 2 to 5 of U
to the third d u but it's really
important to realize why we changed our
bounds we are now integrating with
respect to U and the way we did it is we
used our substitution right over here
what x equals 1 u is equal to 2 when X
is equal to 2 2 squared plus 1 u is
equal to 5 and then we can just evaluate
this right over here let's see this is
going to be equal to the antiderivative
of U to the third power is U to the 4th
over 4 and we're going to evaluate that
at 5 & 2 and so this is going to be 5 to
the 4th over 4 minus 2 to the 4th over 4
and then we could simplify this if we
like but we've just evaluated this
definite integral now another way to do
it is to think about the is to try to
solve the indefinite integral in terms
of X and use u substitution as an
intermediate so one way to think about
this is to say well let's just try to
evaluate what the indefinite integral of
2x times x squared plus 1 to the third
power DX is and then whatever this
expression ends up being algebraically
I'm going to evaluate it at x equals two
and at x equals one and so then you use
the u substitution right over here and
you would get this would simplify using
the same substitution as the integral of
you you to the third power do you use
the third power D you and once again
you're going to evaluate this whole
thing from x equals two and then
subtract from that it evaluated at x
equals one and so this is going to be
equal to well let's see this is U to the
fourth power over 4 and once again
evaluating it at x equals two and then
subtracting from that at x equals one
and then now we can just back substitute
we could say hey look you is equal to x
squared plus one so this is the same
thing as x squared plus one to the
fourth power over 4 and we're now going
to evaluate that at x equals two and it
x equals one and you will notice that
you'll get the exact same thing when you
put x equals two here you get two
squared plus 1 which is five to the
fourth power over 4 that right over
there and then minus one squared plus
one is two to the fourth power over 4
that right over there so either way
you'll get the same result you can
either keep it a definite integral and
then change your bounds of integration
and express them in terms of U that's
one way to do it
the other way is to try to evaluate the
indefinite integral use u substitution
as an intermediary step then back
substitute back and then evaluate at
your bounds